ahora que ya sabemos cómo dibujar
proyecciones de newman vamos a ver si
podemos aplicar esta habilidad a
diferentes conformaciones del butano muy
bien y aquí tenemos justamente el butano
y vamos a mirar a este vamos a ponerle
digamos esta perspectiva vamos a empezar
a verlo desde aquí de tal suerte que en
realidad los enlaces que quedan opacados
digamos son el enlace entre el carbono 2
y el carbono 3 de nuestro butano muy
bien entonces una vez que ya hemos hecho
esto vamos a proceder a pintar la
proyección de newman este primer este
primer carbono correspondería al punto
que siempre dibujamos aquí verdad y lo
que podemos observar es que tenemos un
hidrógeno digamos hacia arriba y a la
derecha entonces tenemos un hidrógeno
hacia arriba a la derecha también
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia arriba pero a
la izquierda muy bien
pero hacia abajo en realidad tenemos
todo un grupo metilo verdad todo esto
sería como un grupo metilo entonces esto
queda como un ch3 muy bien ahora ponemos
una bola detrás de esta el punto que
corresponde al carbono 3 de esta cadena
verdad y eso podemos ver que hacia
arriba tenemos un grupo ch3 tenemos este
ch3 mientras que tanto abajo a la
izquierda como a la derecha tenemos un
hidrógeno verdad ahí tenemos a esta
proyección de newman que es una es una
conformación alternada y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es ver otro tipo de
conformación es por ejemplo si dejamos
el carbono de atrás fijo qué pasaría si
éste ch3 lo rotamos hasta esta posición
entonces esto puede verse también de la
siguiente forma que podríamos tener
que ahora este s h 3 se encuentra en la
posición digamos de arriba a la
izquierda
hacer bien la línea ok ahí tendríamos
ahora nuestro ch3 y estos dos hidrógenos
este y este pues rotan de posición
también verdad tenemos que ahora se
encuentran a la derecha arriba y hacia
abajo
ahora bien el carbono de atrás el
carbono de atrás quedó fijo entonces
aquí arriba tendremos
h3 y aquí tendremos nuestro hidrógeno y
el hidrógeno restante muy bien entonces
esta es otra conformación posible
simplemente rotando el carbono de
enfrente digamos un ángulo de 60 perdón
de 120 grados verdad son 120 grados el
que rotamos el carbono de del frente
ahora qué pasa si volvemos a hacer una
rotación podríamos tener una nueva
conformación es decir este grupo metilo
ahora vamos a rotarlo hasta esta
posición muy bien entonces qué es lo que
vamos a obtener tenemos nuevamente ahora
que nuestro grupo metilo se encuentra en
esta posición y en las otras dos vamos a
tener los hidrógenos ok mientras que en
la parte de atrás nuestro nuestro
carbono 3 de la cadena original va a
tener aquí nuestro grupo
ch 3 y aquí los dos hidrógenos restantes
así que todas estas son proyecciones de
newman alternadas para el butano y ahora
necesito pensar sobre la estabilidad de
estas tres proyecciones
y nos preguntamos cuál de estas tres es
la más estable así que si nos fijamos en
esta primera conformación tengo dos
grupos metilo verdad tengo este grupo
metilo y este otro grupo metilo ahora la
característica que tienen es que el
ángulo de yedro o el ángulo
el ángulo que también le llamábamos
torsional este ángulo es de 180 grados
verdad tenemos un ángulo de 180 grados
180 grados esto nos dice que la
conformación bueno tiene un nombre
especial y es la conformación anti ok
entonces tenemos la conformación anti
y realmente toda esta distinción es
porque los grupos metilo son muy grandes
y muy voluminosos y tienen un montón de
electrones distintos que se estan
repeliendo mutuamente así que hay que
tratar de mantenerlos tan lejos como sea
posible los unos de los otros para que
tengamos la conformación más estable ok
entonces ese fue el análisis de la
primera conformación que es una
conformación anti y es la más estable
para estas con formaciones alternadas
del butano si nos vamos ahora con el
segundo caso aquí podemos ver que el
ángulo entre los grupos metilo el ángulo
entre los grupos metilo es de 60 grados
este ángulo es de 60 grados en este caso
vamos a decir que la conformación es de
tipo 2 ok go choca o algo así entonces
lo que tenemos para este tipo de
conformación es es que la interacción
entre estos dos grupos muy voluminosos
no nos da un actor una atención
torsional de aproximadamente 3.8 y los
por mol
como podemos ver tiene una mayor energía
potencial y sabemos que la energía
o más bien para una mayor cantidad de
energía potencial tenemos con
formaciones más inestables verdad o
menos estables en ese sentido el el
segundo caso es el mismo tenemos un
ángulo de 60 grados entre estos dos
grupos metilo entonces esta también es
una conformación de tipo gov y nos da
una energía potencial nada más de esta
interacción de 3.8 kilos por mol si
quisiéramos calcular la energía
potencial de toda la conformación
tendríamos que sumar d también sobre las
interacciones que hay entre los otros
otros electrones
ahora bien cuando tenemos dos moléculas
que tienen exactamente la misma energía
que en este caso por ejemplo corresponde
al 3.8 kilos por mol verdad decimos que
las dos con formaciones son son se dice
que son de generadas ya que tienen la
misma cantidad de energía entonces
déjenme escribirlo de estas dos con
formaciones son de generadas muy bien
entonces ahí tuvimos las proyecciones de
newman para el butano pero en una
conformación alternada vamos a ver qué
ocurriría si nosotros queremos hacer las
conformaciones eclipsadas entonces
déjenme partir digamos de esta de aquí
de esta de esta primera conformación y
vamos a hacer una rotación digamos de
180 grados ahora este de aquí este este
grupo metilo vamos a recorrerlo hasta
acá muy bien mientras que el carbono de
atrás va a estar fijo entonces ahora
tenemos
nuestra nuestro primer carbono y en vez
de tener una conformación digamos de
tipo i va a ser una invertida ahora
vamos a tener aquí nuestro ch3 este s h3
corresponde justamente este que estaba
abajo y pues tenemos los otros dos
hidrógenos verdad aquí está el hidrógeno
y el otro hidrógeno y la parte trasera
se mantiene igual sólo que ahora está
eclipsado verdad aquí deberíamos tener
un ch 3 también se h 3 aquí deberíamos
tener una h y aquí también una h muy
bien entonces esta es una conformación
eclipsada cuáles serían las otras con
formaciones bueno tendríamos ahora
quizás ahora lo conveniente es si vamos
a seguir rotando como hemos estado
haciendo tomamos este y ahora lo rotamos
hasta esta posición verdad entonces qué
es lo que vamos a tener nuevamente mi
carbono de enfrente
nuestros tres enlaces pero el grupo
metilo ahora se encuentra acá abajo
verdad mientras que dejamos los
hidrógenos de este lado ahora bien cómo
quedan los enlaces del carbono
trasero pues sería nuevamente un ch 3
aquí aquí tendríamos un hidrógeno y
tendríamos otro hidrógeno entonces
nuevamente esta es una conformación
eclipsada
pero habiendo rotado este grupo metilo
vamos a rotar nuevamente este grupo
metilo ahora hasta esta posición verdad
entonces que es lo que vamos a obtener
tenemos aquí nuestro grupo metilo
tenemos que rellenar con
los hidrógenos verdad con los hidrógenos
ponemos el carbono trasero y aquí se
mantienen igual verdad tenemos nuestro
grupo ch3 tenemos nuestro hidrógeno y
tenemos nuestro hidrógeno y ahí tenemos
las tres distintas conformaciones
eclipsadas para el butano
ahora vamos a pensar sobre su
estabilidad muy bien entonces en mi
primer ejemplo teníamos dos grupos
metilo muy cercanos verdad de hecho el
ángulo de yedro entre ellos es de 0
grados eso quiere decir que va a haber
una un impedimento esther y con mucho
mayor verdad entonces esta interacción
esta interacción que tenemos por este
por esta cercanía de dos grupos metilo
nos arroja un una tensión torsional de
aproximadamente 11 kilos jules por mol
mientras que la interacción entre los
hidrógenos como ya habíamos visto es de
4 y este también sería de 4 entonces
esto nos arroja un total de 19 kilos
jules por mol verdad esto es la energía
potencial o la atención profesional
total verdad que tiene esta molécula que
ocurre con este caso bueno también vimos
en el vídeo anterior que una interacción
entre un grupo metilo y un hidrógeno nos
arroja un
una atención de 6 verdad 6 kilos por
móvil mientras que aquí sólo hay dos
hidrógenos eso nos da cuatro y aquí
tendremos otra vez interacción de
hidrógeno con un grupo metilo nos da
seis en total son 12 más 4 son 16 kilos
jules por mol y en este caso es igual
verdad aquí tenemos 6 aquí tenemos 4 y
aquí tenemos 6 entonces tenemos 16 kilos
jules fórmula entonces si nos damos
cuenta estos dos últimos casos
nuevamente son son con formaciones de
generadas sin embargo la que tiene una
mayor energía potencial es este caso
verdad y es justamente la más inestable
de todas las conformaciones ahora vamos
a ver un un último ejemplo que sea muy
parecido al caso anterior ahora vamos a
tener nuevamente una cadena principal de
4 átomos de carbono digamos un butano
pero vamos a agregar aquí en vez de un
hidrógeno
llegamos aquí en vez de poner un
hidrógeno vamos a poner un grupo metilo
ok entonces como ya hemos visto en
algunos vídeos de de nomenclatura de
este es el 2 metil butano verdad ahí lo
tenemos déjenme poner aquí los otros
hidrógenos
y este último hidrógeno entonces vamos a
ver las proyecciones de newman son las
alternada vamos a fijarnos sólo en las
alternadas ponemos aquí digamos nuestra
perspectiva desde donde vamos a ver y
ponemos está digamos esta línea para que
quede muy claro de de cómo va a ser
nuestra proyección de newman entonces
este sería nuestro primer carbono este
sería el carbono trasero ok entonces
tenemos este primer carbono que es que
lo representamos como un punto sabemos
que arriba a la derecha es un grupo
metilo verdad sería este grupo metilo
un grupo metilo arriba a la izquierda
tenemos un hidrógeno y hacia abajo
tenemos otro grupo metilo verdad tenemos
este grupo metilo ahora bien vámonos con
el carbono trasero verdad hacia abajo a
la derecha tendremos un hidrógeno hacia
abajo a la izquierda tenemos otro
hidrógeno y hacia arriba tenemos un
grupo metilo ch3 muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos una conformación de newman para
el 2 metilo está no vamos a ver qué otro
tipo de conformación es podemos
encontrar ok entonces ahora yo creo que
lo más fácil es rotar el carbono de
atrás verdad y esto es más fácil porque
solo tenemos un grupo metilo entonces va
a ser más fácil de checar vamos a rotar
esto digamos
vamos a rotar los 120 grados de tal
suerte que este grupo metilo quede ahora
en esta posición entonces dejamos fijo
el carbono de enfrente aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno aquí tenemos un grupo metilo
aquí tenemos un ch 3 también ok y ahora
rotamos las posiciones de estas tres
entonces este grupo metilo ahora
quedaría en digamos en esta posición y
el resto eran hidrógenos muy bien aquí
tenemos otra conformación posible para
el 2000 butano es y es a su proyección
de newman y finalmente vamos a rotar
nuevamente este hasta esta posición muy
bien entonces aquí tenemos nuevamente se
queda igual verdad este es un hidrógeno
un ch 3 abajo también queda un ch 3 pero
ahora en la parte posterior vamos a
tener aquí un grupo ch3 acá arriba un
hidrógeno y acá también tendremos un
hidrógeno entonces vamos a ver ahora
cuál es la estabilidad digamos de estas
tres distintas conformaciones y lo que
podemos ver aquí es que hay una
interacción o más bien hay un ángulo 10
de 60 grados entre estos dos grupos
metilo y quedamos que esto es un una una
conformación de tipo gaucho boat ok y
sabemos también de lo que vimos
anteriormente que cada una de estas
aporta un 3.8 kilos por mol muy bien
entonces esto es más o menos esto es un
3.8 kilos formol extras verdad entonces
creo que es el único que tenemos en
cambio aquí por ejemplo tenemos 22
cercanías de ese estilo verdad tenemos
dos gauchos
dos de estos y eso nos da un total de
3.8 3.8 son siete puntos seis kilos
jules por mol
en cambio aquí sólo tenemos un gaucho
un gaucho y esos son 3.8 kilos por mol
entonces si sólo nos fijamos en eso
podemos darnos cuenta que tanto éste
como esta primera conformación son las
más estables de estas tres que hemos
pintado verdad y eso es porque tienen la
misma cantidad de energía y es la más
baja recordemos que la mientras más
energía tengamos es menos estable así
que este de enmedio que tiene 22
interacciones de tipo gaucho suman 7.6 a
la tensión torsional y eso hace que sea
menos estable verdad es la molécula va a
tratar de gastar menos tiempo en la
conformación del centro verdad aunque
sea alternada ok y más bien va a tratar
de parecerse a cualquiera de estas dos
que se encuentran a los lados muy bien y
eso es porque si tienen solo una
interacción de tipo gaucho ok entonces
estas serían las dos con formaciones más
estables y por supuesto son de generadas